my ice cream like chocolate I like pizza
and cheese like a dude is hurt ain't
dance night dance Steven I just got
dance oh my god
[Music]
worst fire team ever raid run first
attempt
I have no footage of these weak snap
you'll see me snap on the radar now I
don't want you I want you to kill it
I'll snap on the right I don't want you
to snap that's not what you wanted
yes here we go on it and you'll get it
and then you'll get it
it's about our little Frankie okay how
that right nice we'll get one of those
portable systems hey what's up by the
way jarhead and it's good to see you on
bro I just want to give a shout over
head hey we heard a nice man we hear
your name dutch master can you hear me
yeah I hear ya yeah we got kicked out
regular Channel but you're back now yeah
we need so you're gonna have to explain
a coke which I'm nervous about you're
not the best at that are you that's
asking where orbs are at he can't see
you shining blue orb in front of his
[ __ ] face god dammit Craig here we go
so how does this work Joe hello are you
happy are you happy yes yeah yo Steve
we're all broadcasting let's go I'm not
broadcasting all right you want the
footage okay what do we do if should
just kill these mold
no wait wait what coke explain it
alright okay alright so we gotta go we
got to go through this don't shoot any
of these enemies these enemies won't
follow us okay
they'll just follow me alright [ __ ]
doesn't look crazy though
oh this could be like ten hours dude
come on well I got a call Volger cuz
there's two Steve's now no I'm not
looking any I just want to pull this
ball in his face don't don't shoot him I
can look at them Oh y'all got correct
have it I don't need to stay together
yeah I got mine Griffin yeah alright so
focus and follow Colton gets over to
quit yeah this is exciting
be careful when you fall here cuz you
can get hurt I just just look at them
yeah yeah wait why is Stevie I don't see
your thing working
are you sure it's on this is off line
mean I'm on line are you sure yeah
alright
oh this maybe it's going like maybe my
shaco alright let's go Oh broadcast
again I'll try it again yeah try it
again I think you're not broadcasting I
want to make sure your footing that's
alright Griffin we'll get it next time
next time you're on yeah yeah I got it I
got an air unclear audio into everything
make sure you include your audio into
everything everything I could in my
audio yeah you know on my audios
included
okay cool you know what I could do that
can its work myself alright let's do no
I don't know where anyone is okay you're
behind me we're all here right
we're all here why can we start killing
chi or pollen come not yet up here
remember somebody do this Kraig record
just the game footage but I you know
what I mean yeah but that's fine that's
fine you can find cuz we'll have the
audio any we'll just cut you in the
corner we've done a little frame in the
past oh man I'm let me go boys keep
going keep going here I'm coming I'm
coming I'm coming
hold on keep coming around that room
there you are you're coming toward me
just gonna leave me this is dishonorable
we gotta get these these three relics
and slamming into this to open the door
so this thing all right this thing yep
so we're gonna need
let's do three people here clearing adds
because there's gonna be adds constantly
coming out and then I'll be right here
two others will come with me the right
other people should clear adds right
yeah Griffin and stand I'm vulgar
okay let's Steve stay here cuz he gets
nervous when he's got a gravity why no
no no no follow me so Craig and Steve
follow me let's go come on Stevie Oh
late level does matter here though right
I'm just saying he should be okay this
would be fine dude why you make
today I just wanted to make a point that
way level matters
just do your corporate job I'll peek at
you
where's your mom at I want to say what's
up she's in her room
you've been missing out on the hall you
listen I know you don't understand we've
been we've had our conversations about
it the fact you might be gone soon we
should talk about that
we're V ads no no thanks everything
kinda wanted by us the ones right I'm
gonna come they're gonna come to schooi
quizzes pirates white level remote yeah
reloading you me the after kill grants a
brief period of invisibility wow that's
cool yeah what is it perfect
I've got one of these chords to record
the audio and all that but it just
didn't work sucks the funny part is to
get to the actual [ __ ] first level
six levels how do you go invisible we
have to kill something and then you
reload great well how many do we have to
kill though they keep coming back
there should be a big boss coming out
you guys keep clearing I'm gonna check
over here
might spawn over here [ __ ] we're bumping
into each other hold on what's up all
right
enter the pleasure garden oh here we go
oh man I'm gettin hurt I'm about to get
my super house to come back up
I know me too Steve you got a healing
rift oh you threw it up yeah I didn't
know you threw it up super journey
damn I hate these shield guys dude
there's such dickbags shoot their feet
trying you're like die hard
all right the bong a the boss is over
here all right let's go Stevie let's go
to work coke is go to where on that
where are you on the other side yeah
yeah I need to switch my guns work for
my name [ __ ] oh no you're I'm not where
you are I don't know what I'm going man
he's down below he's down below loop
around down below just loop around I got
this big bastard on me
yeah there is okay
there's some orbs Craig I don't see you
guys man we're underneath or underneath
behind just where we were oh here ate
the coke
I mean we're gonna slam-dunk the thing
here they're gonna slam-dunk it right
here and we got a defendant to make sure
none enemies touch it or they're gonna
take it okay all right
hey do them banana Steve good ready to
go let's do it but do it what's up
Suge it's wrong one no slamma-jamma we
might have gotten the wrong son this
one's the son what are the axes to go
back out and in or something oh this is
the cub yes where's the Sun at the Sun
comes out the Sun always like either you
don't just put your super call it out
okay well is there another place for the
axe is that a different one we can start
with or not these are the these are the
only ones that know do we need to go
with him then no no no no no just stay
there we've got to find the other flag
there has to be a Sun flag again I'm
[ __ ] dead all right well I guess you
so this is the axe what is so funny man
how you you re already revived there's a
there's a [ __ ] sweating underneath
for that [ __ ] yes underneath yeah I
think there's a waiter don't know I've
never had hold on do we know what we're
doing there's just like this gold
chalice just then there at the there at
the Sun so where's the Sun one that's
the only right I'm following general
Craig now what are you about to do we're
gonna is it does it not start on a lower
level is this the only level it starts
on as this top level
I swear Dean these are the only one I've
seen so how did how did you start it
though didn't she start the raid with
somebody
this is all we did I've never had I'm
looking somewhat isn't gonna huh
all right guys where's the flag Jesus so
people have done this [ __ ] they've
completed this [ __ ] oh there's not many
yeah in six hours one of them - wait
wait Arthur not many I'm just kidding I
know someone who's completed it twice
already
Wow well but she's on PlayStation okay
I'm going to the guide right now all
right for defenders will stay on the Sun
point defend it two adventurers will
claim objectives at some point will
display one of three symbols found cups
swords - standard seekers must
communicate as symbols being displayed
once you know was it practically in the
chorus by a standard oh yeah okay that's
not that you'd probably it might be a
different one maybe it spawns different
ways yeah I see a different flag over
here well Steve is diddle it what what
is this is the axis or axis you put the
ax writer so we have to find another one
right is that what you're saying what's
it what's it say on the on the middle of
the platform we take it - is it still
son Jesse right over here look what's on
the top now or you were defending what's
on the platter the gun the Sun the Sun
Sun okay so this is the pig right down
here oh it shows the ax here do you have
to put the ax here I think yeah I think
with maybe there I'm gonna get it right
a vulgar of all right up there well you
have
yeah yeah well I see we got a do we have
to defend this area while they get the
other right I'm gonna use my slams which
area Ohio cocoa cooker okay okay guys
come to us down riff down drip down put
a shield here oh my god I think those
orbs back that's so sick so Opie I don't
even know where you guys are right now
we're where we were Steve were you where
we love the beginning where we were in
the beginning
oh my bad all right there's guns that
[ __ ] let her where's the [ __ ] all
right you know I'm liberated it there I
gotta go get the chalice all right so
he's gonna get the chalice right above
us
we got we got this we got now put this
here hey if you see a guy with an
invisible shield over them like a scion
you've doand in the bubble and melee
them cuz they make their guys invincible
you gotta kill those okay got it uh all
right I'm gonna take this big boy out I
mean you need help here I'm gonna go
help you no I'm good man I'm good
you sure Sonne got some guys there's a
big guy over here
kneeling roof yeah we got get these guys
with the shields the yellow bar dude Wow
oh I got a bright in ground nice special
oh there's that guy you gotta there's
this guy oh [ __ ] he's right I got him I
killed him I killed the guy - somebody
get me up yes yeah go back go back we
get you back to back to back
there we go
[Music]
we're staying here he's gonna bring it
down now we're killing every skill yeah
just kill there's a lot folk is the only
one that needs to do anything right now
anybody got healing rift thank you more
seconds cheers Haley all right these
guys I hate these almost almost barrier
dudes my controller is just shaking like
crazy dude yeah cuz we're killing her
man I'm dead closer where are you I'm
gonna I'm in I'm just in the middle of
everything
getting hit yeah we all are yeah we all
are just thing with that I got it you
got it laughs the way
how you doing I hope you need help I'm
no I'm good
just grab it
hold on grab it there you go I got it
yes help me take out this [ __ ]
really did they who I think so oh the
guy with the bubbles through here yeah
they did come out take him out yeah I
gotta Mario God we got a really defend
guys you're putting up healing rest all
right I gotta go get that Cup again yeah
guys make sure they don't get to us save
supers for when they get close if I did
that time but anybody else got a super
ready to go
no no yeah we alternate supers
do you have to fight that dude again
cocaine
yeah I gotta fight him out God she'll
get another but she'll really really
ones gotta give you remember that be
great
no [ __ ] right I got no [ __ ] amo -
Craig can you come help yes yes I'm
going you guys defend yeah I got I got
no ammo sidearm alright well I still
play over here
where are you Koch are you over where we
started or just look for my name okay
getting close I see his pride comment on
our knees down there's another guy
coming it's getting close I got them
about halfway
oh my god know that you'll use your
space I got our guys don't call it do
they they took another one died guys do
it
alright well let's get this right we got
a defend better well it's also it helps
when the two of us grab the flag because
then we can get this guy down with her
all right
all right got it all right here it comes
kneeling right other were those guys the
big guy yes have somebody has special
I'm dead I'm dead took another one you
got to get in there bubble you gotta get
in there Bob yeah that's okay I got it
yeah oh yeah yeah you have to take all
the food yeah take him out alright where
do we gotta go folks a healing rift
swords so left this way
okay well I can't use this rat King I
got to get rid of this raccoon
I got a useful I got to get my [ __ ]
wrist want her back
yeah just use what you're good with
speed just pay attention to these dudes
and when we Koch brings back the things
make sure they don't touch it all right
we're gonna reset it's this one right
okay so what do we have to do just shoot
every one of the guys here is serious
get this chest piece that I have you get
you get to ozonate he's immune oh you
got oh yeah it's the fall guy
I got him yeah I'm going this mobile and
mail in killer I got it all right here
I'll be the designated person to take on
the mill yeah we got this last time he's
down here comes another one
you got it go go go super time just keep
going over come on just keep killing
come over cars just nothing make sure
they don't touch the thing hey char left
or left got it
alright alright alright no I gotta get
the phone I thought we had it all okay
no they got two of them all right
defending this guy's alright I don't get
it
all right let's go coast comes another
one [ __ ]
the shit's fun is this fun to you guys
this is fun [ __ ] huh yeah this is a lot
of fun I'm so happy that we're doing
this yeah this okay idiot hook he's here
he's here
yeah I'm here I'm here they're here yes
you don't let them grab it
do not let them touch it Zoop all
watching the right side talk to put it
in explain and healing rip in the middle
where's the state not they almost got
this do we almost got because remember
if they're in that bubble you got a you
got it get in you got a male am all
shitty kill me coke there's the bubble
guy right there right there male will
die live hey Liam hey Liam I see em I
see em oh I see the bad they took all
right so ii was you don't we should one
of us should go get the guy in the
bubble bubble bubble guys are the main
guys i tried getting some there you got
a killer you're gonna choke right in
front of you guys yeah let's he thank
you goes through here and there's like a
right light or 11 million you guys
should be able to just master your super
of just for those guys like that should
be the main thing special all right
where are you coke where'd you go soar
down there okay
you mean axes you mean axes yeah
whatever
I got no arms up there if you guys want
to grab them yeah I'm shooting this
[ __ ]
hot damn alright putting down a Bubble
Boy Bubble Boy got him
we're got him okay good yeah gotta Mars
so one of these standard liberators all
about these days these guys in the
yellow you got to make sure that they
don't get for those flags he's gotta
defend Healy right all right I got it
let's go all right oh that's not a good
sign
okay it's okay okay good vibe
thank you that's all right super nice
super super nice nice nice
all right they got it they got it I'm
going what's next we gotta get I think
it's up top right I am gonna try see if
it's up there um so look like it's here
yeah it's up guys I need help they're
coming anyways just a photo boy forget
them yeah just use your super on those
guys we're good
where is this [ __ ] we got to kill
these ads there we go there there is
super
I think it gets easier after this though
because I remember we only threw down
[Laughter]
I'm going after boy all right I got it I
got it let's go are we doing here right
here behind you guys I'm here guys token
shader you beat it you turn it into them
and you get you guys job guys
yeah nice job we got it yes good job
yeah good job so what do we do now you
guys hey let me just say do you guys
remember do you guys remember the like
the relay race
tell you right now we're not gonna do
this one reward we are not on this one
let's be kind of positive one no no this
isn't the one I thought it was this is
the Guardian cram the guard but even
even I don't even I don't even I don't
know I feel like we're really doing some
hold on Craig Craig I'm gonna tell you
Craig okay I'm gonna tell you this [ __ ]
is so complex I did it with guys that
knew what they're doing we went through
it right away but I literally listen to
them I different all right dude let's
just try can we try can't do a different
ride let's master Steve I would say I
would say let's try but I honestly don't
even know where to start
leave our jacks cold
okay Pleasure Gardens once you have
opened the hound doors you'll have
Pleasure Gardens a lush jungle full of
Cabal so we have to jump on all these
like gold things on all these gold
things nah hold on hold on I'll tell you
what it is okay hold on I I'm reading it
right now all right so I'm dead you will
soon come to learn the Rings okay
we got to take down the enemies once the
enemies are down you'll notice what do
we do
once all the enemies are down you will
notice two large crystals spawn at the
back of the room near the giant statue
callous statue at the foot of the statue
there's a large room a round door with
three lights on it this door leads to
the safe room which is crucial mechanic
in this counter before the fight starts
break your team up into two groups of
two and four for roamers will grab spore
balls and sneak around
two spotters will jump on platforms of
crystals and guide the roamers I'll [ __ ]
the encounter is just as simple just as
simple spotters spotters grab the
crystals and stand the light while Romer
sneak past patrolling hounds to reach
the spores on the road the spores the
spotters channel light into the spore
making them explode granting damage buff
to the entire party lose as many times
as you can before the hounds begin
attacking you out of restlessness or a
timer these are the spores Steve okay
the spores let me see okay let's go let
me wanna see spores okay those are and
then you have to bring them hold on hold
on hold on I'm looking at the map here
you should probably change yourself you
know what I'm gonna I'm gonna change him
I'm Ida and my thing so I can go fast
like pretty fast yes mark that's a smart
yeah as far as guys with crystals and
stand on a light so we stand in the
light the spotter stand in the light
there's two spotters and the roamer
sneak past the hounds to get the spores
when the rumors make it to the spores
the spotters channel light onto the
sport and make them explode oh yeah you
shoot a beam of light onto them so so
pretty much this is the light this is
the light by the way using these beams
we yeah we had we had we sneaked through
because that's what we did we sneaked
through with four people you get a
damage buff every time you kill no
spores so we got like a plus R times 72
damage buff because when the yellow
beasts come out like the dog things they
got so much health their bullet sponges
and you got to take them down before
they they consume those spores and you
got to make sure that you can kill them
all so you that's what they're saying
you're trying to get as much of a damage
buff as possible that way you can take
them down so
again so here's what we have to do
there's four people going for the spores
each person grabs a spore prices sneak
you're gonna try to sneak past the dogs
so like you don't want to get that
you're basically kind of defenseless
when you have one so you want to get
past the dogs and you want the guys see
these lights up here so the guys with
the crystals has to jump on these
platforms and try to hit the spore guys
and then explode them so basically you
have to aim toward the guy holding the
spore to blow and that gives you a
damage buff so you can eventually
destroy I guess the hound dogs so the
whole thing is to kill the hound dogs
with the spores and then those platform
well you get a buff right you get a
damage protector okay but I think you
know do it just shooting them with their
guns no I don't think so
eventually no you get the max DPS yeah
you are shooting them you're shooting
them and killing them
okay bye give us more okay so all good
so these crystals wait so these crystal
things you have to pick up we have to
sneak on the ground I know the crystal
the crystal thing the crystal guys
should jump to these lights right here
okay that's what I'm asking and then and
then they should shoot the guys with the
spores that the spore guys like here I'm
bottom below you shoot the suppose
unless close eyes only so there's a
whole lot of this community to critical
holders they have to have one each side
with the forespore guys oh okay so I bet
it's gonna start when we get the
crystals so whoever wants to get the
crystals out I could do a crystal I'll
try it go my way okay what's the easiest
the for the for people that are going
down and sneaking you stand here and
you're gonna write your don't know where
you are
he's right next to you Steve in the
middle where you just were
right here where everybody is Steve
words right here cuz this thing's gonna
come out and you're gonna go underneath
and everybody grabs a thing down there
and then we try to the crystal guys you
have to shoot your guy with the sport
explode okay we have bad listening
skills so is it easier to be the prison
weapon guy or is it to be the guy
sneaking both tough they're private of
ice ice nook and this guy knew the route
perfectly like that okay
okay so so you're the we're navigating
if you have this prism and you're on one
of these things you're telling people
where to go go left go right so then
right now I think so so it's like you
know so then is somebody like Craig
needs to be doing that because he likes
to like you know tell people what to do
this [ __ ] won't listen to do
[ __ ] he'll be like what I want to go
right yeah yeah but I'll tell you why to
go right I want to go right later
charged so Craig should definitely be
one of the crystal guys you know all
right I would like to be a crystal
holder - okay so Craig hits - forget the
crystals okay let's try it let's just
try it
let's all be on this one yeah
you'd be on the other one all right fine
I'm gonna pick up the prism weapon
already we need you bulgur much do it
order
get get where we're at what's up a
vulgar there he comes
all right here we go all right I got it
I got it
importable Rock all right let's go
there's the dogs okay some guy left come
on he's not abusive growling all right
there are they going they're going Steve
okay I'm on I'm here all right shoot me
shoot me shoot me
I can't I'm holding a rock Steve you got
to jump to these platforms and we didn't
get it
well [ __ ] we're out I gotta jump back oh
[ __ ] wait what happened to my god allah
hath won every what happened to me the
thing disappeared
yeah they think that they're howling
it's all over Oh
oh I see I see okay I see yeah the
shooters man yeah we're the [ __ ] the
spores I don't see they're in there's
lawyers there in the corners there I
don't even know what I think let me let
me see where the spores are I don't we
picked it up and this is worse than crow
- man this is here who is the worst
crota with a neat quota was an easy
Raymond Griffin robot yeah no no he
might as well just die Oh might as well
wait and start over
okay so let's before we start it let's
go find where the spores are guys let's
just do that they think there's four of
them and they're in the corners there's
a map to it this there's six spores so
okay so here we go come down here let's
go to the six spores all right follow
corporate Craig so we gotta kill these
guys we got to kill these guys too let's
kill these guys
there we go all right so this is war
there's one right everyone look right
here okay get these stupid dogs all
right so we should plan out which is for
we're gonna go do that yeah exactly
then Spore number two is I thought you
know room where we just dry here here
come here
thief yeah I'm outta here dude
here's sports yeah it's real easy this
is only a semicircle
alright then sport three sport three is
over here maybe no this hose this is
where we're taking them this is what
there's like basically it's like four
corners of a room and that's right
so there's what's so there's there's one
here one the first one one three four
there's supposed to be four here's
another one there's one here let's just
map where are you I'm right here right
here here's one there should be three
okay so here's one come back this way
just to go back through you know what I
shouldn't be I take the thing back I
said I shouldn't be the one shoot once
cabbage here's another spore here okay
so those are the two then we start with
one two over here that should be the two
you guys are going for somebody should
go for the far one and somebody should
go the far one right here and somebody
should go for that first one on the left
okay I'm gonna take over for Steve I'm
gonna do the thing I'm gonna pick up the
prison okay then then if we go all the
way around there should be more spores
over here
over around this corner this Bend here's
another one so here's three it says six
but I only see four here's three where
I'm at wherever you guys are coming
right here you see three
where's everybody everybody else I'm
watching from right over here I see you
okay I'm just making sure everybody sees
me and then four should be back here
here's four coke you're kind of quiet
man are we doing okay what's the deal
number yeah no this is what you do yeah
that's it
then you're gonna then you're gonna get
to a place where you're holding it and
we're gonna shoot it now do the I don't
think they have to come back anywhere
let me look at the map that we just have
to thing is and shoot get those those
hounds we can't be seen by those hounds
right okay well I like that it's like
that it's like the Gordon yeah it's like
yeah yeah so here's the thing I can show
you where the three hounds are gonna be
okay because I mean on each side
there's there's five hounds okay so
there's one mountain right here no we
can do - more there's one hand looking
at this sport right and his pathway is
he kind of goes in a circle I think
around this beam right here so you're
gonna have to be careful so you don't
have to rush it I don't think we just
have to get around him
so what you trying to be patient what
you probably want to do is grab the
spore you don't see him and we're back
here and then have the person up here
shoot it another thing you guys could go
we should do it one by one you should
travel with that that's how it is how we
did it okay so that's what we're doing
guys can I show you the rest of the dog
movement so you guys can see it so
that's just the first dog there's one
that goes around this barrier okay
then the next one he kind of does a wide
long one like this he walks back and
forth okay no one's even following you
yeah
[Music]
I know but you should be watching you're
not following him
yeah it's you Galactus what are you guys
doing come here
so there's one look if I map this is
visible okay but there's one that goes
right around this thing this beam right
here then there's one that walks this
way strain of agate for all this [ __ ]
I'm just telling you there's one that
walks right now but there's also there's
holding them crooked three guys there's
only three right then there's one that's
back here that comes in around okay
there's one that's back here that goes
back home is it okay I know I got it I
just got our here's that last hit is
four
here's number three on this yeah here's
number three so this is the third one so
this guy yeah so you want to go to the
team right yeah yep
all right so if you're going if you're
gonna go on the right side then me and
Griffin should be on the right I guess
together to shoot who's holding the
stuff me and Griffin okay all right
let's do it let's try it
Griffin let's grab the rock and we'll go
to the right or no I guess we gotta go
the light over here
I guess each of us travel underneath
I know grab one of these fine all right
how do you shoot with it you just hold
down right if it goes on it's weird what
we're trapped
because we ran too quick I guess I don't
know we took the stones and they
disappeared I guess we gotta get to the
different light I guess we can't do it
Griffin you go on that light I'll go on
this light we gotta stop them from how
driven you see them on the ground
anywhere
do you guys get one okay that's the idea
we just got to be able to shoot them
quickly oh sure okay let's go everybody
we're dead guys let's just start let's
like white if we have to shoot our guy
that's poor once they get the spore they
have to go we got this for us all right
let's just wait but the way you guys did
it as we hit all these floors and got
time to settle into damage and then we
all killed the hounds at the same time
that's how low oh but how many orbs did
you get before you shot them
dude you die just by them looking at you
you're dead we we got times 72 so
however many that is it was a lot oh
yeah you don't know how many orders
Philippe okay we drop down do we
immediately pick up the purple stuff
yeah yeah all right okay hey Griffin do
you wanna do you want to take left and
I'll take right I just want to see if I
can ever find them to shoot in the first
one we should shoot all these guys they
said kill all these guys firsts here
kill all these dudes on the ground
so you guys are just gonna hit that
first spore on the right right yeah well
we're gonna go ahead before together
okay guys as a group okay father cool do
we kill everything guys okay did we
didn't kill her yeah no I don't all
right here we go let's go let's go
all right let's go go go go go go
I have to pick it okay what do I do
run to the light run to it but to the
light all right I pick them on up how
are you all right
slow shoot you guys wait I want [ __ ] all
right this one right there yeah but I
got back up back up back up then I pick
it out love it hold on where are you
guys the hounds coming around yeah all
right okay let's start over
that's the idea I saw okay I did it I
did it
let's humble so like here's where it is
right here I just need you guys to be
over here so I can shoot it this is the
one you guys should really omit damn the
helis damn
that's annoying
I cook how do we do that round make sure
cuz I gotta just make sure I can see you
and shoot you so I just want to say we
made a little bit of progress yeah we
did we're going to the right first no I
know that I know that I know that I just
there's multiple beams of light I just
want to make sure I'm on the right light
and you guys are right below where I can
shoot you that's all I want to make sure
okay so when we pick up the purple thing
and we go next to the spork do we have
to hold X or anything or doesn't no no
no you just got to make sure you see me
and I can shoot it that's it Oh like
shoot the thing in my hand yes I have to
shoot yeah you're holding that's what
I'm saying okay now cuz you like we both
can shoot through it so we should both
go to the right then right no no but
don't do it because light disappears let
me just tell you because I tried it
black one time Griffin the light
disappears and I can't I can't get it
just disappears on us are crystals
disappear so you just got to go to the
left for this one and then we'll see how
it works so here's the first one right
guys is this correct just come see where
I'm at yeah this is the one this should
be the one yeah first one
somebody says yo coke if you guys stay
all together and hit the spores it's
more efficient right we got that um like
four orbs once for 120 multiplier move
as a unit holding the spores okay so
here's a move together so here's the
first one so I'm gonna be right in this
light and I just need to see us so if
you guys back up to here
fine as long as I can let's true shoot
it again okay I think it like right are
you hit in there
yeah he's paying attention who's hittin
a steam yesenin yeah Stevie but Stevie
should be paying attention look you're
gonna go or Pikachu it so like a kid
throwing to Ted's attention it's just
low we're gonna be right there
[Applause]
all right great yeah but don't let the
dog see you don't let the dog see you or
it's over I let's start but but my
dilemma is yes what's okay my only my
only question is like so you're gonna be
shooting them from there and I'm not
gonna shoot them from anywhere not yeah
one of these other line yeah no no you
should go to the first light on your
line again passes first we should go to
the first light on your lap yeah just
follow got this okay all right
yeah it's ready let's go I got ya yeah I
got the rock I'm going to the light I'm
a purple that's a dog's gonna come all
right there's the spoor here it is
the dogs below it so be careful I got I
got a purple yeah follow me follow me
follow Coco
who saw us that dog and the dog saw me
when it all came on us
you got a state crowd got a state caucus
so we had a Crouch okay so let's wipe it
will do together
all right that's why well that's bad bad
we know where we're going so that's good
[ __ ] you
you dog alright alright sit across
hidden you guys need to move when the
dog isn't route the other way okay
alright cool I'll just be in a little
more patient and we got a got a Crouch
alright alright so and then he says so
the Guardians on top have to tell you
how the dogs are moving yeah so okay so
Craig I don't need to come yeah but you
don't need to come that far out if you
stay back further I think you'd be fine
oh Jesus
alright done your Pikachu if we don't
revive him the light goes out with that
we're dead where are you I'll get them
I'll Bolger why are you dead I slipped
and fell oh alright make sure we're
communicating guys don't look we've won
mercy well and if one person dies it's
over that's the other thing yeah if we
don't revive it if they die and we don't
revive them in this game over all right
let's try we gotta kill all these dudes
still we gotta kill all the adds
[Music]
I mean if we get past this part of
that'd be great this is all yeah I mean
miracle huh yeah be great I don't know
it doesn't seem that bad at once we
figure it out
it seems like as long as you guys worked
we work together no and that's the hard
part
good let's go yeah wait there's still
another bad guy out here I gotta kill it
or it's not gonna start here it's over
here you guys okay you guys you didn't
see us on your radar right yeah but I
can I can see you guys so I know where
you're going is correct you just went
too far out you just have to stay back a
little so I'll try to tell you that oh
you're starting okay well we are fine
yeah let's go all right wait what are
you guys huh
is everyone here okay go go go
I'm gonna shoot where to stop I'm
shooting where to stop you see my light
yeah okay they're dark oak all right I
got it stop stop stop no we got to be on
it get back to back to back to back to
back you gotta wait for this dog to make
a route okay
so dogs their ways coming towards you
back up back up
ie sauce okay Ross back inside
we could start it over I think as long
as nobody dies if you come upon maybe I
had bad breath yeah I guess there's no
way that I'll stop it that's it if he
sees you were dead
it won't were making progress that's
okay yeah you left
yeah well know who left it sick
definitely fired or not I said cannot
could not connect you're definitely
servers checking network connection
alright well we'll wait for you hear me
yeah but let's do because I'm still
online cuz I'm talking to you guys yeah
but you just gotta sign back out and
back in or one time back in yeah so
Craig Craig he's gotta tell us where
those dogs are gone no no I understand
clarify no no we're dead we're dead I'm
dead I know but we can't you need both
people to be here okay so here's where
I'm confused I'm shooting you with the
ball but it wasn't doing anything yeah I
wasn't doing [ __ ] huh do you have to get
all of them or something like this is
what I don't understand okay as far as
grab crystals and stand alight well
Roemer sneak past patrol to reach going
sores so I don't that's what I don't
understand it's saying I'm supposed to
be able to blow them up but I was
shooting you in the whole time and it
wasn't doing it so difficult due to high
amount of communication smell also the
dogs the balls
spotters grab crystals that's me and
Griffin and stand on the light well
roamers sneak past the hounds to reach
the spores when the roamers make it to
the spores the spotters channel light
into sport to make them explode so
where's that first spore cuz it's not by
me it's not where I'm at
it's it's over here where are you guys
drop this near the dump it's underneath
and you're gonna dog
no no it's near a dog and not we're dogs
something is
hold on hold on let's just clarify when
we all get kill these ABS I want to make
sure I understand where you guys are
because you get the spore and I don't
see it oh [ __ ]
we started active yeah yeah yeah yeah he
can join us anytime okay here yes yeah
okay hold on
so before we do anything you know
can we invite you co can we imagine coax
Matt oh folks back so folks said BRB
guys listen oh alright
so ya all need all four need to be close
to the floor okay hold on let us so let
me just show you some stuff because I
want a corporate Craig isn't perfect
Craig is it grasping don't know here
come here come here come here come with
me come yeah this part is tough requires
skill and communication yeah so great so
come here coke where are you coke yeah
he's on the side so here I rap yeah let
me just show you come follow me cuz I
want to clarify with you because you've
done it so we grab this right this is so
not fun is it I just want to bail in
place I'm crucible hold on hold on
before we do that close come here you
grab this right here look at look at
this this is the first light i have
right here see this first light right
but yes you have a light layer you're
coming from over here in the purple yes
the treasure yeah but there's a hound
there's a hound right where are you
getting the first foul where are you
getting the first purple from over here
there's the first door you're getting
the purple inside of you
yes yes all four okay so [ __ ] the unit
but listen listen
yeah you need there's a dog right by
this I understand that dong and I need
to tell you when he's gone when when can
I blow up the spore that's the question
I was shooting the one you were when the
time when the dog is gone and we're all
by the sport we gotta all be by the
spore yeah so yeah so that perfect thing
there first I see a spider it's your
first job your first job is to tell you
what okay if it's safe for us to go okay
I got you all right that's what I needed
to know so that purple thing you're
holding is not the Spore it's that first
spore you're gonna have and I'm gonna
okay see that's what I didn't understand
to light those spores up we need to have
these orbs and right I got you see like
I thought the orange you were holding
was the sport that's oh no I can't
believe I just [ __ ] didn't know what
I didn't know but I didn't know you hold
on I'm back he's laughing no he said I'm
an idiot
and then he was laughing what did you do
where's Steve yeah you're right jarhead
I was confusing it that's right hey
Arthur do that do that move again that
that breakdance move yeah the twitch
this is why okay but what was water coke
what was the problem
what do you mean are you ready let's say
guys let's go guys all right I got it
now hold on already grabbed it so I'm
grabbing it [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] all
right there's a dog out there don't come
out the door closed he's going to the
left
but I need one any left sneaked up but
don't don't don't go yet hold on he's
coming back he's coming back don't go
yet wait wait don't go yet
don't go yet back up back up all right
back up as soon as he turns around yeah
I'll tell you she turns around look I'll
tell you oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
he's coming back that was backed up all
right he's going left he's going left
he's going laughs he got ya sneak up no
Go Go Go Go Go Go Go tires one keep
going Jimmy there we go ahead okay
follow me your body blocking you boy
watch out watch out there's another one
dude follow me oh there's a dude here I
didn't realize there's dudes here all
right that's good okay so we got the
idea here so what you're gonna do is go
around at this circle we could do this
this is doable as long as they tell us
that they're okay I know I know I didn't
realize there was guys I have to shoot -
I think I think that's Mariah Carey we
just got to know where [ __ ] that all
right yeah that's Mariah Carey so that's
all I got to figure out there so there's
guys that pop out and shoot me ain't
Griffin so Griffin we got to shoot these
guys that come out so I think yes you
know you're holding that yeah yes
crystal yeah that's what I was doing
yeah I didn't know they came out so
that's number one so I'll shoot we'll
shoot those guys and then then the next
dog okay so now we just got to go the
next dog
so they're gonna close on the serve we
could do this yeah that's what I'm
saying
[ __ ] where'd my dad go [ __ ] here we go
okay I just want to see my map here okay
so I go there to the first one okay then
I got to go all the way around to the
back right corners the second one can't
we shoot the dogs with this crystal yes
but yes we can shoot them and kill them
but I think the idea is to this as many
get the damage buff we got if you want
to do it right we want to do it as many
times as you can before they begin
attacking you all right and we got to
kill them all you got this we got this
so here's what so anyway let me just
show you guys can I just show you the
route so we can do this once so I know
what to do now now we know what to do
[Music]
you are yeah what are you talking about
it's like playing with the word known I
know he's talking about code I play wid
Thor's he didn't say I'm he's talking
about himself well I appreciate that
coke
- would ya III don't know never mind
I was trying to trash-talk you but I'm
tired of it alright lot of this [ __ ]
alright everybody let's just grab the
spores no no no let's not let's just do
this like gonna show you all right and
let's sneak around we know this is the
first one right we know this is the
first one okay yeah we know
okay stop yeah yeah then you're gonna
come over this way okay you're gonna
come around this tree and [ __ ] okay and
you're gonna go to this back right
corner right here you got to give me a
second because I gotta get up to this
yellow mark right there I gotta get up
above you okay well that's I mean that's
the first two steps right right right
right but let me just wait dude cuz you
guys got to know the route let's just
plot this out then you got to come
around here and you got to get to this
spore right here I'm the only one
following you no one's following you I'm
Steve I'm right here dude I'm gonna come
over here you guys are gonna go between
these rocks I think you're gonna have to
find a way between rocks no no you are
just guys come here you're gonna have to
go between I'm on top of you I see where
you're going and you're more now this
squeak Griffon this becomes you Griffin
this becomes you
they're gonna come over this way and
they're gonna come around here and
they're gonna grab this for over here so
that one I should be is you should be up
in this light on right here right here
oh yeah right there on this you got to
look for the dogs
you gotta lure the dogs at home where
the dogs are and then once that dog
disappears you're gonna come around and
you're gonna grab this one if you can
get to it and then Griffin you're gonna
shoot it from there
and then I think that's pretty much
there's one more over here if they can
make it in time thank you so you're
gonna jump to this light for that last
one here this one right okay so that's
it so that's all right the dogs panting
captain Koch dogs okay here hold on is
Baxter coming back crowd he's coming
back purple thing man I shouldn't shoot
the dogs right no not yet
don't mess nice guys follow coke don't
come out yet he's coming right towards
you I know I know I can see oh no he saw
you oh what the [ __ ] is that
how does what did he see it yeah I told
you guys not to come out yet
we were I don't know he came at you
there was nothing there's nothing we
could do there I let's wipe let's try
again but that's the idea I don't know
why he saw you guys I don't even think
by the way that have done to all the
spores to do it by the way I think we
just have to get a majority of them and
try to kill you
we got 72 more you don't want it oh my
god these dogs are so hard to kill
that's why that's why we need that
amplifier that's the whole point yeah
because they're too hard I'm still alive
[Music]
the worst fire team podcast episode
alright let's try it again
hey we got this that's right I feel like
we actually try it if we actually tried
all right okay is that better thanks TV
I'm trying I'm trying to get like number
well yet don't forget we get dope loot
if we finish this [ __ ] I know I just I
think I think we should make a shout-out
to you boy he's watching this stream
because he literally told us or tell you
at the spores who which dude
shouts and I follow me on stream dark
let's give
I don't know let's give them a shout-out
now you don't match our boy who that his
name your boy Oh Lord yeah no it's not
my lord I just said it's cool dude it's
uh it's yeah yeah all ready everybody
ready let's try here we go having the
crystal I'm going for a walk soon okay
buddy darn so now we're not [ __ ] room
all right I'm not leaving this room
until Craig tells us to okay don't leave
don't leave don't leave it and I get you
guys yeah
gosh all right let's go Jia no no don't
don't do anything don't do anything cuz
I can't I can't shoot them from here no
no yeah you gotta be next to sport
lemondogs
I don't mean to die he's coming toward
me know when he's now he's moving so go
quietly he's moving he's moving he's
moving come up come up it's going Crouch
crouch crowd we're in there I keep going
straight keep going straight keep going
straight now I gotta shoot this guy oh
no we have the Frog this next guy
where's the next one next one's over
here nobody's over here don't bother you
keep coming toward me up watch out watch
out stop behind the rock stop buying the
rock laptops up back up back up go back
back back around to the right go back
around to the right go back around the
rocks alright keep going around the
right go around the right no no the
other one guys no no no no that's left
for me it's my right sorry guys go
straight come toward me come toward me
come toward me quick watch out now this
guy's might turn around so this is great
we're doing great
yes stay there stay there back up back
up back up back up back up stay there
stay there stay there yeah he's coming
fright behind us though
no no don't worry about that guy stay
where you are telling you okay okay come
on come now come now coke coming out
coke or vulgar whoever's got it go up to
go straight go straight toward the pod
where are you going to the behind you
behind you yes coke right there right
there you guys are going the wrong way
you had to go toward Co right here where
the pod hey we may we made progress to
be progress
yeah that was good dude we actually
could have done it do it again let's
wipe and do it again right away we
actually made progress and actually we
were pretty close dude you guys are
really close but stay with coke coke you
be the front man mmm because you were
going the right way they were all
walking away from
are they not seen I don't know either
dude but I don't know how that is we're
gonna glitch
alright so that's your left I'll try to
remember my right your left
yeah all right all right I got you it's
just tough because the stupid dog walks
around the whole [ __ ] thing how come
my name's the only one without to zero
to nine remember last night I told you
how to join the clan you got to go on
Bungie no no you don't know you don't
all right Steve Presta the the the
that's the button on the right the
little button on the right you know I
mean when you go up here press the
butter on the rice you go to the UC
which says character go to the left I'll
be the clan oh yeah you're gonna get
some gear brother yeah yeah and then go
to your invites the second thank you you
know you see your yeah go to invites and
then the folder where it says 2029
pressed that and then you say except
there's a whole wide well I can't
well how do I get in invite them clip
clicking a to get in the envelope won't
let me go in yes it's buggy won't have
any yeah if I didn't you don't have any
at the Senate okay let me see if I can
send them so no one invited me thanks
guys hurts me I mean with you know
that's Koko's doing with you guys for
years man all right hold on hold on
and I'm doing the things these DB we've
I saw I saw it yeah yes I know I saw it
tonight like it Steve won't let me send
him one you mean scary buzzing me scoffs
yeah pretty much yeah I told you he's
got to do it actually that was scary
stand by me right now I don't know I
might I don't know why
all right coke you ready we'll figure it
out later yeah I'm ready yeah
here we go I got the crystal okay got
the crapola spot here coming at the spot
where's the dogs gonna grab the paper
then come started with dogs
all right the first dude still don't go
yet he's gonna come towards you you
should stay back I don't think we're
timed on this right no no it's no
cinnamon be be chill just gotta be chill
yo impatient okay he's coming towards
you guys looking like a dick bag yeah I
want to shoot stuff you know I mean
Jesus all this together there we go all
right this guy's gonna come out of the
room I'm gonna kill him I'm going to the
next one guys so hold over stay there
for two seconds all right think you got
to go around hold on oh [ __ ] no oh God
see oh oh
very bad [ __ ] up right yeah all right
wife way
it's cuz he doesn't know that jump oh my
god Pikachu when either me stever kind
of dad we're gonna take that [ __ ] soccer
I mean so we just placed I'm crucible
well let's try a couple more times I
just feel like do we haven't even given
a real chance to like I I know what to
do do it for the first hour with the
purple [ __ ] ball let's try one more
come on let's try it let's try it I
think one more and if we don't alright
one more I'm crucible you guys are the
worst
good that's to the name
tell you that we're living up one more
time one more time by the way hopefully
by next Friday guys new podcast coming
out yeah sure keep telling yourself that
I know we're loved in private Pikachu
that's great
no way all right need to kill this last
dog there's one more dog way down there
I'm outraged already okay here we go
here we go now when you get down there
try to keep it down cuz I gotta tell you
where to go all right I'm going go go go
go the dogs down quit [ __ ] around
okay I'll tell you when he's walking
toward you or he's walking towards you
okay
hide behind the plants guys camouflage
in the plants with the glowing light all
right here you put these plates he's
walking towards you stay back all right
he's gone go go go go go go
stay right by me
why is it not glowing but is it the
other one no it's not glowing backup
you're shooting this Wars dude no it's
supposed to light like a beggar better
are you eating in the light yeah dude
it's not working right dude something's
not right did you guys grab it right or
something well I'm back come back to it
make sure you guys blast it blasted dude
now it's not purple it's well it turns
purple when I can shoot it it's not
turning the other one what other one
dude there's no dude it's not no no no
Griffin are you on a light patch yes oh
yeah you know get off of it Becca Becca
Becca Becca Becca Becca Becca back up
back up back up back up
hey says says it has to be lit up is it
lit up now no it's not lit up watch out
he's coming that looks good come back
come back let's see what Holly and
they're probably on probably the other
side of the map you said so let's look
over here yeah it's over here it's the
other one so perfect oh they're coming
to you then Griffin so you have to get
on a light so every but all you guys
come over here all right we got it and
grant you all the way I gotta come over
here oh [ __ ] I fell
your dog right here okay wait wait wait
wait wait now let's see to it that's it
the Royal beast grows restless I think
that's okay trying Griffin can we [ __ ] I
know August right here all right flash
flood there you go all right crowd there
you go
there's a dog right next to us yep cool
coming in more he's right there yep we
got to get another crystal yeah the
Beast the Beast is done as we've seen oh
wait we got we get it no more damage we
got that powered power in twelve percent
yeah yeah but we gotta kill a bunch of
them
we kill this [ __ ] we kill this
[ __ ] okay I think we can do it I
think we could do it okay oh my god more
time yeah but it was good I mean we're
getting there like we know how to we
know how to do it guys I didn't know
that I was supposed to be looking for
something glowing like that but now that
I know I see it oh yeah yeah I know
which one it is
hopefully it goes so I didn't know I
didn't know I thought I'd work around I
thought it showed up when they showed up
cuz that's what I was doing for me so I
didn't realize like it shows let's just
go let's go right to it let's go right
to it well you know this guy's gonna
kill these guys I really wish we didn't
have to kill a Dodge Pikachu in to try
and find me this is the funnest part
that we get to shoot [ __ ] yeah through
is there an easier part of this rate and
is it random is that why we got sent to
this one first
it is no this is my feel like because I
did the pools first last time I did it
pools it's like a relay race I know you
guys love that [ __ ]
yeah I don't actually this one's
actually better buddy because you don't
have the pool I don't know I don't know
I feel like once you're getting the hang
of the relay race it's really not that
bad well maybe
I feel like as long as you guys stand
together and do that like forget it I
mean if we can do so many to multipliers
so we were at 12 so they get seven you
know how did they get so many orbs I
don't know
okay here it is got a lot all right here
we go yeah he had it mapped out dude we
literally did it in two tries like I
didn't really know what the damn guy
alright corporates are draw the map
Bedell aisle it's like it's this one
over here by me again okay okay - like
there's a dog here okay he has some no
you're gonna watch the route every wait
wait wait wait wait this dog is walking
targets Walker so if you guys start to
get ready to sneak all those be ready to
sneak behind it
oh you should have come all little orbs
might be a bad idea all of us are gonna
attack them for all their all right
which we're gonna to the right to the
right he's around the beach behind
Griffin oh [ __ ] the guys are out itself
stuffs up
we need backup go this way you go to the
left yeah look out no go straight right
there like a bat back back back
yeah go left my ass let him walk or
think that where's the next one let me
go guys you guys he's coming he's coming
Griffin they should be - they're all
right really
I don't see another thing lit up over
you go to the next gold one all right
let me see if there's a good sign
is there one lid on your side I'm
looking back it's not no it's not that
one so let me see if it's one in the
middle back up back up back up back up
back up ugh he's coming
oh god it's way over by the far crystal
remember the second crystal coke by me
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah alright okay
what's that
hold on yeah yeah goes back hold on dude
here dude all right follow me all right
be careful go hold on oh no oh god they
found stop stop stop stop stop stop stop
stop okay no he didn't see you hold on
he's walking he's walking the stupid dog
guys walking he's coming back to the
left okay
come out come out can we run with ya
come out and go go blast me go around go
around keep going keep going
follow me hold on okay hide behind that
rock I behind that rock like you did the
last time yeah I'm coming over here
vulgar get get back let's do you know
what I strike now Craig says it break
[ __ ] up just so annoying
I'm trying to help you get three at
least you tried now wait we'll do it
we'll do it eventually yeah yeah at
least at least we know I gotta walk my
dog it was good playing with you guys
yeah see you Stevie Stevie
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]